[Music]
hey I'm Dan MA and I'll be your tour
guide through this analysis of the debut
trailer for watchdogs legion lots to get
through here so let's get to it
yes as teased at the end of watchdogs 2
we are in London here we can see a big
chunk of the south bank and the borough
of southwark with the shard looming
large in the foreground the London Eye
tucked away in the background and the
Thames sneaking through England's
capsule I can see my office from here
we're in the future people how do I know
this not because of the neon trend
Routemaster bus or the drones but
because Big Ben is tall and proudly as
it's currently as a service for repairs
until 2021 back on the south bank this
is City Hall official office for the
mayor of London and referred to by some
as the onion presumably by people who've
never seen an onion the real deal
doesn't feature such heavy-duty branding
it appears to be a logo for some sort of
next London initiative which might
explain some of the scenes we'll see
later
to your right ladies and gentlemen some
Paul's Cathedral pleasingly devoid of
any neon upgrades take note of the
digital science at in front stating that
ID checks are mandatory for a hashtag
secure London we are in Orwellian
surveillance state territory here rather
worryingly they've chosen to illustrate
this with a fingerprint that resembles a
skull although any British people
familiar with TV licence ads will know
that's par for the course for government
advertising come now - good run there
for a while false and ominous
incidentally this is Camden Market home
of alternative fashion bootleg t-shirts
and piercing studios it's a good sign
that Legion is going to show some of the
less ubiquitous sections of the city -
oh here we go
it looks like London is under the
stranglehold of a private military
company called Albion and that people
are having none of it and look at that
advertising rarely have a slogan and
image seems so at odds with each other
bombings
seems that someone's got it in for the
Canadian embassy they must really hate
poutine there people thrown in cages
like animals why not stay at the Albion
immigration process center offering
zero-star accommodation and terrifying
drone concierge service these particular
killer robots are attempting to disperse
a peaceful protest in Trafalgar Square
the only way a killer robot knows how
judging by the placards and banners the
Metropolitan Police are no more and
homelessness is even more of a problem
than it is currently the 99% of us can't
be wrong banner is evocative of the
Occupy movements we are the 99% slogans
not sure who this burning devil meets
Grim Reaper effigy is supposed to
resemble yet note of the throne of
firearms could this be somebody in
charge of Albion or even a key
government figure another beautiful shot
of the city full credit to the design
teams what must ranked as the best
looking virtual London ever just like
the previous games it looks as though
we'll be exploring a city that captures
the feel and key landmarks of the
location even if it's not a complete
one-to-one recreation Albion is making a
killing you can always count on
protestors for a macula wordplay it's up
to us to take it back this particular
altercation is taking place on the
corner of Coventry Street and Haymarket
mere meters away from the iconic
Piccadilly Circus the dead giveaway is
the fountain on the Left known as the
horses of Helios for any overseas
viewers we are marginally friendly as a
tourists than this we need to recruit a
resistance viva la resistance could this
pigheaded cigar-chomping be our
potty-mouthed narrator is the game's
cover star so it's a possibility we join
these street performers on Camden High
Street that big dragon on the building
behind them is actually there there
seems to be a return to 70s Punk style
judging by the beatboxer rocking a Union
Jack leather jacket and spikes choker it
makes sense considering the original
scenes anti-establishment routes great
low cap on the dancer too and a good
indication of the sorts of incidental
NPC animations you'll spot as you roam
around only they're not really
pcs as will soon learn I know to
thinking where do we start
looks like someone's set up shop on top
of Tower Bridge cop wait to cause chaos
up there notes these little devices that
appear to be implanted into every
citizen's head more evidence of
government surveillance or the latest in
wearable tech open your eyes and take a
look around look here look it in no not
him
in foramen mi5 okay now we're getting to
the meat of what watchdogs legion is all
about watch dogs had aiden pearce watch
dogs too had Marcus Holloway and watch
dogs Legion has everybody well the 99%
at least the X spy that you see here is
simply an example of one of the game's
many archetypes the expires that you
recruit to your resistance will have a
different name appearance personality
and backstory as you can see here you'll
be able to customize them with cool
masks that are incredibly inconspicuous
we're now getting a good look at
London's nightlife here Chinatown in the
heart of Soho is one of the few places
where the games artists probably have to
tone down the amount of neon lighting
[Music]
got kicked out of Oxbridge robots for
teaching them to reproduce I'm sorry to
report that there is no such thing as
Oxbridge robotics school yet what we're
seeing from London's answer to lisbeth
salander here is the spider bot a nifty
addition to your hacking arsenal that
lets you stealthily and painfully take
down Albion grunts like an electrified
face hugger
problem denlon bonus points for
deploying that most British of insults
Bell end I won't explain it here but
urban dictionary is your friend not
everyone on your team needs to be a tech
wizard the bare-knuckle champion
provides much needed muscle and offers a
great demonstration of the variety of
play styles you can adopt also shown
here is the completely overhauled melee
system and bare-knuckle boxing one of
the many side activities available
[Music]
language gran I wasn't kidding when I
said you could recruit anyone to the
cause this is about the point we should
have realized that watchdogs legion
isn't taking itself too seriously unless
this particular image reminds you of
your actual grandmother in which case I
would really like to meet your nan
Piccadilly Circus it had to be in there
somewhere
speaking as someone who works in that
area for over a decade I can tell you
that it looks absolutely spot-on notice
also the strange embellishments of the
Union Jack flag the blue element taken
from the cross of son Andrew looks
closer to black and the central cross of
some George now has a yellow trim
there's definitely a story there oh and
remind me to check how traditional oil
masters at the National Gallery you can
recruit anyone to landmarks for the
price of one here you've got hms belfast
a world war ii warship turn museum
permanently more than the thames and in
the distance the Tower of London home to
the crown jewels and at least six Ravens
at all times true story
circling what appears to be a heavily
converted BT tower is a familiar logo
that of CTOs creators Blum Corporation
CTOs is the operating system at the
heart of all watchdogs games so can we
expect to exploit CTOs 3.0 this time
around
great to see London's Council of states
represented here although not so great
to see that they've become even more
overpopulated with favela style stacks
yeah I'm thinking about wireframe
crown'd what this shot also hints at is
multiplayer Legion also features four
player co-op missions we're putting
together top teams of complementary
classes or no doubts be critical to
success fine more evidence of legions
revamped melee system which looks
wonderfully smooth and bone-crunching Li
impactful there's a real sense of
connection between the resistance
members blows and the Albion grunts
reactions which is a tricky thing to
achieve we're almost at the end of the
trailer and finally packing this is
classic watchdogs and Albion vehicle
being remotely controlled to cause chaos
he isn't getting up from that speedboats
and Battersea Power Station confirmed we
are firmly in end of trailer crescendo
territory now but let's take a moment to
appreciate the fact that you can surf on
a drone for spectacular views of the
city who needs the London Eye more
wonderful masks and nice to see someone
representing everyone's favorite
fictional football team Kensington
Rovers and here's our friend mr. piggie
again who on closer inspection is
chomping on a flare not a cigar that
monocles a lovely touch - and there you
have it your first look at watchdogs
Legion launching on March 6th 2020 this
looks like watchdogs let completely off
the leash with a wildly ambitious and
original open-world concept that
dispenses with the idea of NPCs almost
entirely married to a boldly topical and
satirical premise can't wait to discover
more
[Music]